completa el cuadrado para resolver 4 x
cuadrada más 40 x menos 300 igual a 0 y
si te das cuenta esto es un caso
particular de lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado así que déjame escribirlo primero
para que no se nos olvide que es lo que
queremos 4x cuadrada más 40 x menos 300
igual a 0 y yo lo que quiero es resolver
esta ecuación completando el cuadrado y
bueno en el vídeo pasado encontramos la
solución general para las ecuaciones se
han logrado completando al cuadrado por
lo tanto voy a hacer lo mismo que hice
en el vídeo pasado y lo primero que hice
fue dividido todo entre 4 por lo tanto
me va a quedar 4 entre 4 llevan ya cansé
del término que está el lado del ex
cuadrados y sirve sencillamente me queda
x cuadrada 40 entre 4 me da 10 10 x y
después me quedan menos 300 entre 4 y 0
entre 4 que es 0 pero cuántos 300 entre
4 déjame hacerlo por aquí y además sirve
de que recuerdo cómo se hace una
división de la manera tradicional así
que déjame ponerlo aquí 4 va a dividir a
300 y bueno 30 entre 4 y 7 veces
4 28 y sobran 2 y después bajó el 0 y me
queda 4 por 5 es 20 entonces se quitó 20
y me da 0 es exactamente 75 entonces
menos 75 es igual a 0 y ahora que ya
canse el coeficiente que estaba al lado
de la equis cuadrada entonces me va a
ser mucho más fácil completar el binomio
al cuadrado perfecto lo primero que voy
a hacer es pasar el 75 del otro lado de
la ecuación y lo voy a pasar con signo
positivo o dicho de otra manera lo que
voy a hacer a continuación es sumarle a
esta ecuación de ambos lados 75 positivo
recuerda que lo que hago de un lado de
la ecuación lo tengo que hacer también
del otro lado y esto me va a servir para
que yo pueda completar mi vida en mi
cuadrado perfecto así que vamos a
agregar 75 de ambos lados de la ecuación
cuando esto voy a poder eliminar el 75 y
pasarlo del otro lado con signo
contrario entonces a esto le voy a
agregar 75 y al otro lado también le voy
a agregar 75 y que me queda me queda x
cuadrada más 10 x 75 y 75 se van 1
negativo y uno positivo y del otro lado
me queda simple esencialmente 75
esto es igual a 75 y date cuenta que
aquí dejé un espacio en blanco porque en
este espacio blanco voy a completar el
binomio cuadrado perfecto y bueno ya que
quiero completar el mi novela de
perfecto recuerda que en este espacio en
blanco lo que buscábamos era tener el
cuadrado del segundo ternium y quién es
el cuadrado del segundo término bueno
para eso hay que encontrar el segundo
término y bueno el segundo término era
muy fácil encontrarlo tenemos que
dividir simple esencialmente el
coeficiente que está al lado de la x
entre 2 es decir 10 entre 2 lo cual me
da 5 y 5 si lo elevó al cuadrado me va a
dar 25 positivos entonces para ello
tener un trinomio al cuadrado perfecto
aquí lo cual voy a poder factorizar en
un binomio cuadrado perfecto tengo x
cuadrado más 10 x ya esto hay que
agregarle 25 que es el cuadrado de la
mitad de 10 recuerda que el término que
está al lado de la x tenemos que tener
dos veces el segundo término
entonces ya estoy agregando 25 y si le
estoy agregando 25 de un lado de la
ecuación recuerda que también lo tenemos
que agregar del otro lado de la ecuación
eso es muy importante si queremos que la
igualdad de mante
o que la balanza que de equilibrada
tengo que hacer lo mismo de ambos lados
de la ecuación por lo tanto que me va a
quedar x cuadrada más 10 x 25 esto es lo
mismo que x más 5 elevado al cuadrado de
hecho aquí estoy utilizando mi segundo
término fíjate que en efecto me queda
esto es el cuadrado del primero que es x
cuadrada más dos veces el primero por el
segundo que es 2 por 5 10 10 x más el
cuadrado del segundo que es 25 perfecto
hasta aquí vamos bien y después tenemos
que sumar 75 más 25 en lo cual me da 100
a continuación lo que voy a pasar es el
cuadrado del otro lado de la ecuación y
fue a pasar el cuadrado con su operación
contraria que es sacar raíz cuadrada si
yo saco raíz cuadrada del lado derecho
en ecuación me va a quedar una raíz
positiva y una raíz negativa de este
lado me va a quedar más menos 10 y del
lado izquierdo sin de sencillamente me
voy a quedar x 5 es decir x 5 es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 100 que quienes es
más menos 10 no vayas a decir que es 10
porque entonces vas a tener la mitad la
respuesta y bueno ya que puedo encontrar
las resoluciones o x más 5 es igual a
dispositivo o en su dado caso x
es igual al menos 10 negativo y bueno
como yo lo que quiero es despejar al x
entonces en ambas opciones lo que voy a
hacer es restar 5 de ambos lados de la
ecuación menos 5 aquí y menos 5 acá de
tal manera que del lado izquierdo
solamente me queda x y del lado derecho
me va a quedar diez menos cinco lo cual
es 5 y aquí voy a hacer lo mismo voy a
restar 5 de ambos lados de la ecuación
de este lado izquierdo me queda simple
excesivamente x y del lado derecho me
queda menos 15 y ya tengo mis 2 raíces
que raíces que x igual a 5 y x igual a
menos 15 solucionan esta ecuación de
segundo grado es decir que cuando yo
sustituyó la x por los valores de 5 y
menos 15 en esta ecuación en la ecuación
original voy a obtener que el resultado
es igual a cero o dicho de otra manera
estas dos son mis raíces de mi ecuación
de segundo grado pues la cual yo empecé
y vamos a comprobar que en efecto es
cierto voy a probarlo para la primera
raíz x igual a 5 entonces me queda 4 x
25 que es el cuadrado de 5 más 40 por 5
menos 300 y vamos a ver a cuántos igual
a esto 4 x 25 100 40 x 5 200 y después a
esto
a 300 perfectos y funciona con esta raíz
bueno pues si yo sustituyera el valor de
15 en esta ecuación también nos daríamos
cuenta que nuestros resultados sería
igual a 0 y entonces nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo